of course there's still plenty of talks
surrounding TJ Holmes as a GMA anchor
faces new cheating allegations we're
filling in for Amy robach and TJ Holmes
well he and Amy Roebuck remained
sidelined for the third day in a row a
source claims to ET that TJ had an
affair with a third woman who no longer
works at ABC that's in addition to Amy
and a former GMA producer I'm such a
marriage component I want everybody to
get married the source adds that TJ's
wife got suspicious this summer while on
vacation in the Bahamas celebrating his
birthday quote they had already been
through so much trying to fix their
marriage after his affair with a former
GMA producer and then she saw a birthday
card from Amy that was way too familiar
The Source adds she was done after that
I think you start with marrying someone
who was considerate and kind and good
which he is so that helps because you
have a good foundation to start with
yeah it's getting messy In This Moment
from the past has gone viral I would
love to hear do you guys do you guys
like the show of course we do addicted
yeah yeah that's Amy with Reese Withers
spoon talking about the morning show
which yep also had workplace Fallout
after two co-anchors have an affair but
I am so mad at you there had to have
been a million and one women out there
who didn't work
I think that you're jealous because of
our history does it hit home we can give
you a few more plot lines
I think we already did that he did yes
Reese's interview was back in October
about two months before TJ and Amy were
outed I have nothing but love for him
and I hope that he's okay meanwhile Don
Lemon who used to work with TJ at CNN is
supporting his former colleague I don't
know about their situation I'm not privy
enough but I just like to offer people
love and support and I hope that they're
okay and I hope that they continue to
prosper and I hope I get to see them in
person again soon so I can give them a
hug